how could mice my student is it has to
be challenging but manageable if I make
it too challenging I'm redlining him
he's gonna break his knees gonna pop
he's gonna be unmotivated if it's too
easy he's gonna be bored I have to find
the right amount of stimulus so when I'm
in the practice room if I see George's
just mulling guys and destroying them I
have to make it have to scale the
workout so that it's harder but I don't
want to scale it so high is that I enter
him and break him or that he made it out
of practice by a hair and he's not
motivated to do another camp you know we
reached those high intensity levels
periodically throughout the year and
they have to be done in a certain way
that it's fun like you know George was
like you know he was on your show and he
was saying I'll try to kill him in the
practice room now it's true he's right
but I do it so rarely I do it so
periodically and I make it a joke that's
why I like what he was trying to say is
I brought in the guys in there in the
room
and I was watching him spar with George
and they don't want to touch his face
this is when he was like a megastar like
he was the champ and nobody wants to try
to double like him nobody wants to try
to hurt him because they're like I'm not
gonna come here in his house and try to
show him if there's a respect thing
there's a there's a they're starstruck
you know these young kids so I'll bring
them in and I'd be like listen guys I'll
give a speech the first got a double-leg
him the first guy to put him out I would
put like a $5,000 reward
I think knock him out you know her if
you knocked over geology for 5,000 bucks
George on his back if you put George on
his back if you take him down put him on
his back I'll stop the whole practice
and praise you for 20 minutes in front
of everybody in the gym and and and
students don't get praised by me very
often so George would be like oh they're
coming after me and he would get riled
up and I would do this periodically
rarely right world world title fight you
know stuff's on the line and I need
these guys to actually show me where
George is missing something because when
you have this perfect practice and you
win all the time
mm-hmm what do you work on well nothing
went wrong there's nothing to fix so I
mean there are times where really
redlining have you ever had anybody
knock him out and make that money now
he's been dropped once in practice
pretty badly and it's a funny story but
the money wasn't on the line that time
right so one time he got dropped in
practice and I wanted to stop I want to
pull the plug it was for a world title
fight he's fighting that hardy two weeks
before his fight I was sure he was
concussed and I said George I'm pulling
the other round it was one more round I
said to me coach let me finish the round
I'm okay
let me finish the next round and I felt
that if I pulled him me I would have
killed his confidence Brian I would have
killed his confidence totally so I said
okay you could do the next round and I
told the other guy he was sparring with
don't line a single glove like I
whispered it to him not a single glove
on him just take a mauling and George
went in the next round not knowing that
the other guys not allowed to hit him at
all and he just crushes the guy right
he's a small team and gets that and I
was really really grateful for that guy
the guy was a pro and I was very very
grateful they you know he took the
beating that we asked him to write and
George after was like man I I know I
know it went bad in round four but round
five was amazing I was on fire office
and you were you were you were [ __ ] he's
like wow that was broad for wasn't it
was just a fluke you know like this this
is this is not what I'm gonna look like
round five you know I'm like yeah it's
like and it's good thing it's Friday you
know because I have the day off tomorrow
Mike George today's Saturday he was
shocked he was like today's Saturday I'm
like yeah and and the UFC was there
filming so I had to like look guys that
footage can never air you know that foot
has got to disappear you know they're
like yeah don't worry you know we
understand the fights on the line he was
fighting our hari two weeks later yeah
that's why that fight he was doing a lot
of wrestling because we didn't want to
like even chance I was sure he had a
concussion when he went in that fight
well now pulling the plug on that fight
a lot of people be like hey you put his
lot you put his health online you're
right but it's so much pressure it first
of all George didn't has nothing to with
UFC we kept it from UFC like we told
them like we told the camera guys bury
this like don't report it like George
would never want to back out of that
fight it was two weeks from now
everybody's coming to watch this fight
like this this fight you know it's been
it's been on what he called the
primetime it's been like three weeks
they're filming you know like this is
happening this fight is happening no
matter what you know the Georges in that
mindset and but he went there honestly
like you know after he got dropped
pretty badly
yeah that's you know Forrest Griffin got
knocked out twice before his fight with
Anderson so twice and apparently one of
them was real bad really yeah yes I
think he was sparring with Wanderlei and
apparently you don't spar with Vandelay
no it's just fights yeah I mean he's
old-school shoot the box especially back
then oh my god yeah Forrest won't really
talk about too much because you know he
doesn't want to be perceived as an
excuse but he I mean how many times the
fighters done that many many fighters
has done that countless yeah to the
point where like I just let the fighter
decide no unless I really feel like it's
it's urgent
which is rare that I've actually had to
intervene because at the end of the day
when are you 100% it really rarely
happens there's always something Brian
but the thing about getting knocked out
is that if you get knocked out two weeks
ago your odds of getting knocked out or
significantly higher you know I know man
it's it's it's crazy and Dan Hardy is a
really good strike oh my god that left
hook if it were to touch George George
would have been out like a light
he's got a crazy left hook plus George
was hurt two weeks before you know thank
God I worked out well
yeah worked out great yeah it's a the
balancing act of being a trainer it's
not something that I envy know it's
tough except because I care for these
guys honestly yeah nothing to do with
the business for the money I couldn't
care less like I could not care less but
I know that that guy he's on a one-way
track so if I'm telling him no hit the
brakes and he's saying we're going that
that break in harmony he's gonna create
a friction and create a doubt in the
fighter Rhino you are you all in are you
all in you know because if you're not
all in you're gonna scare your fighter
right there's that to consider as well
yeah